on
reste cette fois on reste au japon avec
cette fois les fuites radioactives de la
centrale de fukushima qui suscite de
plus en plus la grogne et les doutes de
la population elle s'interroge sur les
informations dont elle dispose
réellement critique clairement la
gestion de la catastrophe par le groupe
tepco propriétaire du site il est
toujours ce soir bien difficile de
cerner les conséquences réelles de tout
cela sur les hommes et sur
l'environnement nathalie sapina lorraine
christophe lourd
un niveau d'iodé radioactif 1250 fois
supérieurs à la normale voilà ce qui a
été relevé hier dans la mer à 300 mètres
de la centrale de fukushima le niveau le
plus élevé depuis la surveillance des
rejets en mer
les radiations ne vont pas affecter la
vie aquatique et selon les experts la
vie sous marine ne sera pas touchée au
delà de la zone des 20 km
des fuites dans l'eau après des panaches
radioactifs dans l'air même si pour le
court terme les autorités nippones se
veulent rassurantes à long terme les
conséquences sont catastrophiques car la
radioactivité ennemi invisible est là
pour longtemps des régions entières
seront inhabitables pendant des dizaines
d'années comme à tchernobyl en fonction
des ventes et des pluies les zones
contaminées risque de s'étendre bien au
delà des 20 km d'exclusion ainsi à
ibaraki à la limite d'une zone de 70 km
habité par un million de personnes les
épinards et les laitues affiche des
doses nettement supérieur à la norme
autorisée je suppose qu'on est déjà dans
un scénario qui dépassera largement au
niveau effets
sur la santé humaine sur l'environnement
dépassera largement tchernobyl qui a
beaucoup plus de population exactement
en attendant ceux qui s'exposent le plus
ce sont les techniciens et les
militaires qui travaillent actuellement
au coeur de la centrale trois d'entre
eux ont été gravement irradiés jeudi
pour ce sacrifice il touche une prime en
plus de leur salaire 15 euros par jour